the biggest issue that most people have
between 0 and 3 specifically is just
ignorance people just don't know what to
do you know getting to six figures is
literally just like sell something to
someone like that's that's all you have
to do to get six figures like one
channel one product one Avatar like
that's it you don't have to do anything
else you want to get to Seven figures
then you just do that and then add the
word consistently put the inputs in the
system in a way that's consistent so
that you get a consistent output so it's
whatever way you acquire those customers
whether it was reach outs whether it was
content whether it was paid ads whether
it was Affiliates whether it was
referrals whatever the thing was that
got you the customers do that
consistently and you'll be in a million
which is still only 20K a week it's not
like a huge number